mélenchon soit je n'ai rien à dire
monsieur mélenchon une sortie a
tellement d'autres personnes il faut et
il faudrait parler sa taille lui qu'on
parle de jean luc mélenchon soit qu'est
ce que vous lui diriez vous faites la
reine encore pendant dix jours jean-luc
mois personnes jugeant voilà peut-être
que j'ai un peu plus d'éducation que
certaines personnes mais en tout cas
voilà je suis un peu choqué par en
valeur un manque de dignité je voudrais
simplement qu'on reconnaisse qu'on
enterre quelqu'un qui était pas connue
mais sans labour reconnaissent quand
même bien oui bon on l'a dit balle a dit
me suis dit
je pense qu'il a dit un peu ce que tout
le monde pose c'est vrai que d'ailleurs
on est en train d'en bouffer de la reine
d'angleterre depuis plusieurs jours
jean-luc moi vous savez quand on est
venu dans le taxi vous m'avez envoyé on
parlait de l'émission bon alors qu'est
ce qu'on dit machin le chauffeur de taxi
nous a dit ah c'est vrai vous avez
raison on en a marre de bouffer à miami
donc c'est ce que je disais en effet de
saturation médiatique sur ce sujet alors
qu'il ya d'autres on peut se poser la
question est particulièrement dans un
pays qui est un pays
la république
on a posé la question de faire une telle